[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend als
der Chef des spanischen Fußballverbandes
Louis roviales den Kopf der
Weltmeisterin Jennifer harmoso ergriff
in regelrecht in den schraubstocknamen
und ihr seine Lippen auf den Mund
drückte was hätte sie da tun sollen bei
einer Siegerehrung vor den Augen der
ganzen Welt ihren obersten Chef
zurückstoßen anschreien oder gar
Ohrfeigen der Vorfall war eben nicht nur
übergriffig sondern auch ein eklatanter
Machtmissbrauch doch jetzt wären sich
Spaniens Spielerinnen sie streiten und
ein Großteil des Trainerteams ist aus
Solidarität zurückgetreten als Check
berichtet
als Sportlerin kennt sie Druck als
Mensch er fährt sie in der Zeit neue
Jennifer hermoso gerade erst ist die
Weltmeisterin geworden doch das Gerät in
den Hintergrund weil der spanische
fußballchef Luis robiales bei der Jubel
Feier vor einer Woche mit beiden Händen
ihren Kopf ergriff ihr einen Kuss auf
den Mund rückte öffentlich und vor allem
gegen ihren Willen er muss so musste das
mehrfach in dieser Woche wiederholen
klarstellen der Kuss war nicht
einvernehmlich schreibt sie in einer
Erklärung und ich habe mich verletzlich
und als Opfer eines impulsiven
sexistischen und unangebrachten Akt des
gefühlte die mich nicht zugestimmt habe
einfach ausgedrückt ich wurde nicht
respektiert
Jennifer hermoso bekommt Zuspruch die
rote Karte zeigen Demonstranten vor der
Zentrale des Fußballverbandes dem
Funktionär und dem Verband auch für die
Art und Weise wie mit dem Fall
umgegangen wird viele fordern den
Rücktritt Tobias
doch der verbandchef lehnt ihn ab zeigt
zudem wieder Reue noch Erkenntnis dass
sein Verhalten falsch war bekommt im
Verband Rückendeckung
ich werde nicht zurücktreten ich werde
nicht zurücktreten gleich fünf Mal
wiederholt Ruby alles diesen Satz auf
der außerordentlichen Versammlung des
Verbandes und erhält dafür viel Applaus
so wie alles stellt sich immer selbst
als Opfer da bezeichnet Herr mosso als
Lügnerin
es gab keine verlangen meinerseits und
keine dominierende Handlung jeder
versteht das auch wenn das Gegenteil
behauptet wird vor allem von denen die
den falschen Feminismus Ehren eine große
Geißlein in unserem Land
für den Fußball Weltverband FIFA aber
reicht es die Disziplinarkommission
suspendiert Robi alles heute
vorübergehend verbietet ihm jeden
Kontakt zur Spielerin viele in Spanien
wollen auch den Rücktritt ob alles
ich bin total gegen das was dieser Mann
gemacht hat denn er greift unsere
Integrität als Frauen an
den Kuss gegeben hätte das würde mir
nicht gefallen und ich finde es ist
dadurch völlig in den Hintergrund
geraten dass wir die Weltmeisterschaft
gewonnen haben
wir wollen dass sich der Frauenfußball
und sich die Gleichberechtigung
weiterentwickeln wie die
Gleichberechtigung der Geschlechter
wollen dann ist es logisch dass der
Rücktritt kommen muss
dabei haben Spaniens Sport und vor allem
der Fußball seit Jahrzehnten
strukturelle Probleme mit Übergriffen
und Sexismus mit Trainern wie ignatio
reders der Jahrzehnte lang seine
Spielerinnen quälte oder den jetzigen
Weltmeistertrainer horge wilder dem
viele Spielerinnen maßlose Härte und
Übergriffigkeit vorwerfen ohne Folgen
auch deshalb stellen sich viele Sportler
auf die Seite Herr Mossos wir sind mit
dir Jenny ein Statement das zunehmend
Bedeutung gewinnt aus Solidarität mit
Jennifer her muss so und damit sich
etwas ändert es geht schon lange nicht
mehr am Fußball
ein Politiker ist dank einer offenen
Demokratie zum stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten aufgestiegen
schimpft aber weiter über die da oben
und dass man sich die Demokratie
zurückholen müssen der Auftritt von
Hubert Aiwanger vor gut zwei Monaten in
Erding ging selbst Markus Söder zu weit
der nicht im Verdacht steht bei
politischen Populismus eine allzu
niedrige Toleranzschwelle zu haben wenn
Albaner allerdings in jungen Jahren
tatsächlich ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt geschrieben hätte dass über
den Holocaust spottet und dann hätte
Söder es nicht bei einer hochgezogenen
Augenbraue belassen können zum
entsprechenden Bericht der Süddeutschen
Zeitung hat es heute Abend aber eine
Erklärung und eine Entschuldigung
gegeben von Albaners Bruder Brigitte
einen eindeutigen Beweis hat die
Süddeutsche Zeitung nicht es bestehe der
Verdacht formuliert man vorsichtig dass
der bayerische freie wählerchef Hubert
Aiwanger als Schüler ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt verfasst haben soll zum Einzug
aufs Augsburger Volksfest kommt Markus
Söder heute Mittag als Folge ohne seinen
Vize Ministerpräsidenten
das sind schlimme Vorwürfe im Raum
dieses Flugblatt ist der
menschenverachtend und geradezu eklig
diese Vorwürfe müssen jetzt einfach
geklärt werden sie müssen ausgeräumt
werden und zwar vollständig für Söder
ist die Sache unangenehm will er doch
nach der Landtagswahl die Koalition mit
Aiwanger und den Freien Wählern
fortsetzen von der bayerischen
Opposition kommen noch deutlichere Worte
wer so denkt wer so schreibt wer so
redet zeigt seine antisemitische Haltung
und wenn sich diese Vorwürfe
bewahrheiten dann muss Markus Söder
Hubert Aiwanger entlassen Aiwanger war
erst im Juni in die Kritik geraten als
er auf einer Kundgebung mit
rechtspopulistischen Formulierungen auf
viel und
es ist der Hose mehr als dieses Landes
sich die Demokratie wieder zurückholen
muss und denen in Berlin sagen ihr habt
wohl den Arsch offen heute Nachmittag
weißt Hubert eiwanger die Vorwürfe aus
der Süddeutschen deutlich zurück ich
habe das fragliche Papier nicht verfasst
und er achte den Inhalt als ekelhaft und
Menschen verachtend es geht auch um
Schadensbegrenzung mitten im Wahlkampf
und so meldet sich am Abend schließlich
aiwangers älterer Bruder Helmut zu Wort
und sagt dass er der Verfasser des
Flugplatz war
ich distanziere mich in jeder Hinsicht
von dem unsäglichen Inhalt und bedauere
sehr die Folgen dieses Tuns ich war
damals total wütend weil ich in der
Schule durchgefallen war diese
Darstellung würde zu einem weiteren
Detail aus der Süddeutschen passen das
Flugblatt soll auf derselben
Schreibmaschine getippt worden sein wie
einst Hubert aiwangers Facharbeit aus
der Schulzeit
und dann noch die Frage an unseren
Korrespondenten in München Stefan
leifert Stefan ist die Sache damit jetzt
abgeräumt oder kann das im Wahlkampf
noch eine Rolle spielen
nein auch wenn sich der Bruder jetzt zu
erkennen gegeben hat als Verfasser
dieses Dokuments bleiben doch eine ganze
Reihe von Fragen die Hubert Aiwanger
begleiten werden wie es zu einem solch
antisemitischen Pamphlet im Hause
Aiwanger kommen konnte der Tag heute
zeigt sich ja auch wie schmutzig die
nächsten Wochen jetzt werden könnten und
er zeigt was auf dem Spiel steht die
Reputation eines bayerischen Vize
Ministerpräsidenten auf der einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite die von Bayerns
wichtigste Zeitung da steht jetzt
Aussage gegen Aussage beide Seiten
bleiben bei ihren Versionen Aiwanger
wird jetzt mit der Erzählung in den
Wahlkampf gehen dass hier eine
Hetzkampagne gegen ihn laufe also das
ganze könnte auch noch in einer
juristischen Auseinandersetzung am Ende
vor Gericht münden zumindest hat
entsprechend
herzlich war es nie aber so pragmatisch
dass man in den letzten fünf Jahren
relativ geräuschlos regiert hat und so
pragmatisch dass Markus Söder sich vor
langer Zeit schon sehr klar festgelegt
hat auf die Freien Wähler mit Hubert
Aiwanger als auch den künftigen
Koalitionspartner daran gab es in der
CSU schon immer viele die gezweifelt
haben ob diese Koalitionsaussage so klug
ist das hat sich mit Erding verstärkt
und mit dem heutigen Tag ist die Zahl
der Zweifler daran in der CSU sicherlich
nicht kleiner geworden danke schön nach
München Stefan Seifert
und mit dem Blick auf die Ampelkoalition
in Berlin geht es jetzt bei dir weiter
eins die Kinder Grundsicherung ist kurz
vor der kabinettklausur in Meseberg am
kommenden Dienstag und Mittwoch immer
noch ein strittiges Thema in der
Regierungskoalition vor allem zwischen
Familienministerin Pauls von den Grünen
und Finanzminister Lindner von der FDP
nun wollen Bundeskanzler Scholz und auch
SPD-Chef klingball eine Erklärung bis
nächste Woche aus der FDP-Fraktion heißt
es dagegen mit einer Einigung bis zum
Ende der Klausuren Meseberg sein nicht
zu rechnen ich wünsche mir dass diese
Sachen auch geräuschloser verlaufen dass
wir miteinander verhandelt ist völlig in
Ordnung da gibt es unterschiedliche
Interessen aber für mich ist auch klar
nächste Woche muss es ein Ergebnis geben
da appelliere ich auch an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
SPD-Fraktion inklusive des Kanzlers da
nicht Zeitdruck zu machen um das
Zeitdrucks und eine Einigung Willen die
am Ende zu kurz greift weil wir
politisch und die Details so noch nicht
geklärt haben können
Niger hat die militärhundert die dort
vor einem Monat die Macht übernommen hat
die Streitkräfte in höchste
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt weil die
Gefahr eines Angriffs gestiegen sei die
westafrikanische Staatengemeinschaft
ecovas hatte nach dem Putsch mit einem
militärischen Eingreifen gedroht und
beschlossen eine bereitschaftsgruppe
dafür zu aktivieren
die Wiedereinsetzung des gewählten
Präsidenten
die NASA und das private Unternehmen
SpaceX haben vier Raumfahrer zur
Internationalen Raumstation ISS
geschickt ein Tag später als geplant
sind die vier aus den USA Russland
Dänemark und Japan vom Weltraumbahnhof
gestartet die Cruiser morgen auf der ISS
ankommen dort die aktuelle Besatzung
ablösen und rund sechs Monate im All
bleiben
der ukrainische Generalstab hält sich
über den Kriegsverlauf relativ bedeckt
aber verschiedene Quellen berichten dass
die ukrainische Armee in der Region
saporicia weiter vorrückt ein Kampf um
jeden Meter bei dem Soldaten nicht nur
ihre körperliche Unversehrtheit da ihr
Leben verlieren können sondern auch ihr
Seelen Heil die Kampfbereitschaft der
Ukraine ist zwar hoch aber deshalb sind
sie nicht gegen Traumatisierung gefeit
unsere Reporterin eine brüll berichtet
wie die Armee versucht auch die
psychischen Verwundungen ihrer Soldaten
zu lindern
OW will jede Sekunde hier einfach nur
genießen normalerweise ist der Soldat
kämpft dann der Front bei kohjansk jetzt
hat der 14 Tage frei und erholt sich bei
der Reittherapie
das hatte wohl zu viel Futter
unterhält das ukrainische Militär eine
erholungseinrichtung für Soldaten seit
Sommer letzten Jahres gibt es das Sport
verschiedene Therapieangebote viele
Gespräche
ein Problem wir arbeiten mit
psychologischen Problemen die bei den
Militärs entstehen das sind erhöhte
Ängstlichkeit das kann Aggressivität
sein
Kommunikations- und Verhaltensstörungen
Suizidgedanken
das Trauma des Kriegs auch Vitali weiß
wie sich das anfühlt er verbrennt ein
Bild dass er gemalt hat weil er einfach
nur vergessen will was er beim Kampf um
bachmut erlebt hat
über uns und wir wollten nicht dass sie
uns bemerken dann haben sie uns doch
bemerkt dieser 120 mm Mörser hat alle
meine Waffenbrüder getötet die starben
alle vor meinen Augen ich bin der
einzige Überlebende
Vitali ivanoff ist ganz im Hier und
Jetzt abschalten ablenken auf andere
Gedanken kommen
es ist wie früher noch vor dem Krieg
still ruhig hervorragend positive
Emotionen
auch seine Frau kann mit dabei sein dass
es dem wichtig die Familie sagt der muss
so viel auffangen so viel verstehen
obwohl sie sich seit Kriegsbeginn nie
länger gesehen haben
sich nach eineinhalb Jahren
wiederzusehen das bedeutet einem viel
eine Auszeit einen geschützten Raum für
alle auch darum geht es bei der Therapie
nicht nur Soldaten leiden unter Stress
alle anderen auch alle Ukrainer sind
durch den Krieg gestresst es sind diese
täglichen Bombardierungen täglichen
Raketenangriffe der Russen
je länger dieser Krieg dauert desto
größer wird die Aufgabe die noch auf sie
zukommt
zurück nach Deutschland schwere Unwetter
sind am Nachmittag über den Südwesten
von Deutschland gezogen in Kissing bei
Augsburg pressen starker Wind und Hagel
ein Bierzelt mit sich als es gerade
aufgebaut wurde laut Polizei wurden
dabei mindestens 12 Personen verletzt
sechs davon schwer
und es gibt aktuelle Unwetterwarnungen
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes gewarnt
wird vor ergiebigen Dauerregen in
Süddeutschland betroffen sind Teile von
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
die weiteren Aussichten beim Wetter sind
so morgen regnet es im Südosten
anhaltend anfangs sind auch noch
Gewitter möglich sonst ist es der
wechselhaft am längsten freundlich im
Nordosten das bei nur noch 16 bis 24
Grad die neue Woche beginnt mit 13 bis
21 Grad sehr wechselhaft im Südosten mit
Dauerregen erst am Mittwoch werden Regen
und Regenschauer deutlich weniger weil
dann 17 bis 22 Grad
und jetzt noch die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 7 12 36 37 39 42
Superzahl 2 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 556
das war es von uns gleich geht's mit dem
Aktuellen Sportstudio weiter und Heinz
meldet sich später noch mal ja mit der
nächsten heute Express gegen 0.25 wir
sehen uns morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]